in a previous video i embarrassingly
shared my horrible spending habits and i
revealed my seven dumbest financial
decisions that i made in my early
twenties but today i want to share with
you my seven smartest financial
decisions that i made these choices
whether simple or not have made a huge
impact on my life but make sure you
stick to the end because i have saved
the best one for last for those of you
who are new hello i'm jessie on this
channel we talk about ways to simplify
your life so that you can live life more
fully with less if this topic is of
interest to you make sure to subscribe
for more positive videos like these so
right off the bat the first one is goal
setting when i was in early college i
was in a very difficult period of my
life and in an attempt to find healing
and sort of to find myself i asked
myself questions that i had never really
asked before
like what do i want from life what do i
want from myself and what legacy do i
want to leave behind when i die
and it was asking these sort of
questions that led me to develop a major
goal that i wanted to have a paid for
house by the time i was 27. so
eventually when i met my husband and we
started dating i presented this idea to
him and it became our goal we actually
did achieve this goal but it was not
because i set this like big goal and
then all of a sudden it magically
happened rather what it meant is that we
were able to break this big goal into
smaller chunks but the big goal was
important because it gave us a direction
or a vision of where we should head in
this way we could work backwards and
develop yearly goals monthly goals and
even weekly goals and this became so
important because at the time both of us
had debt i believe that setting goals is
immensely important because this way
you're not just aimlessly doing things
you have a direction you're sort of
carving a path for yourself this way and
it doesn't always go the way that you
plan and there will be detours along the
way but the overall direction does not
change so really quick for those of you
who may not be natural goal setters or
goal setting just might not come
naturally to you i want to share with
you an acronym that may be helpful when
it comes to setting goals and that is
smart this stands for specific
measurable achievable realistic and
timely when it comes to the way in which
you set goals the how you do them is
actually very important if you would
like to learn more about how to actually
set goals check out my two videos that i
have linked in the description below
numbers two and three are school related
and that is that i went to a community
college for as long as possible and i
paid off my school loans as quickly as i
could i don't think that everyone needs
to go to college my dad went as far as
fifth grade that's elementary school he
has rental properties and he loves what
he does but i needed to go to college in
order to become a registered nurse and
while i graduated at the top 10 of my
class and i could have gone to those
prestigious colleges that my classmates
bragged about i just wanted to get my
degree and graduate as quickly and as
cheaply as possible so that i could
start working i took college classes in
high school so that i could graduate
early i took summer classes in college i
worked through college as long as i
could and i commuted rather than living
at the college it took sacrifice i drove
an hour and 10 minutes each way but i
made it work by audio recording the
lectures and listening to them while i
drove and between all of these things i
was able to graduate from college with
minimal debt and i was able to pay it
off quickly and i also graduated college
much sooner than most of my classmates
who graduated high school at the same
time that i did truly i don't think that
for my degree the hospitals that i was
applying for were hiring me because of
where i went to school they were hiring
me because of me so i considered this a
very smart move and number four is that
i invested in myself i specifically took
advantage of employment education i was
an icu nurse for a few years and for the
first couple of years i really just
focused on soaking up information but
after that i became a preceptor training
new nurses i became certified in certain
devices and procedures and i got my
certification in icu as well and even
though i'm no longer an icu nurse i
think that this was a wonderful choice
because if your employer provides you
with free means of getting training
credentials certifications etc it adds
value to you as an employee it makes you
more hirable and it gives you better
opportunities whether you want to
advance or in my case if i were to want
my job back for any reason it would be
much easier to obtain it because of all
the certifications that i have and not
to mention that it gave me little
bonuses and raises along the way so take
advantage of any free employment
education that you have available it can
not only add value to your resume but
maybe your paycheck as well before we
continue to the next one let me know in
the comments what is the smartest
financial decision you have made thus
far share with us in the comments so
that we can all learn from each other
number five is that i focused on
improving communication skills and
self-development i've touched on some of
my mental health issues that i had in
the past in previous videos but there
came a point in my life where i was done
being a victim i wanted change and i
knew that it started with changing this
my mindset and because i wasn't
surrounded by the most positive people
at that time i looked for that
positivity in books i have found immense
value from improving my communication
skills through books like crucial
conversations it has made me a better
leader and has helped me tremendously in
my job and personal life books such as
captivate and cues by vanessa van
edwards have also helped me improve my
confidence and body language and of
countless other books from spirituality
to finance to self-compassion books and
audiobooks have tremendously helped me
shape a more positive mindset and have
slowly transformed my thinking over time
if reading is currently not a habit that
you enjoy check out my video on how to
start a reading habit that i'll link in
the description below reading no doubt
can change your life number six is the
fire movement i am no longer using the
fire movement as a part of my daily life
and i share all about that in a previous
video which i can link in the
description but in the beginning it was
just the boost that i needed to quit my
horrible shopping habits when i
graduated from nursing school i had
major lifestyle creep and i accumulated
other debt besides the school loans and
the fire movement really motivated me to
get my act together sell my crap and get
out of debt it fueled that fire that we
needed to work like beasts to build our
first home as our general contractors
while both working a full-time job it
was just that slap in the face and
wake-up call that we needed to let us
know that our financial future was in
our control and that we could in fact be
financially independent someday if we
were willing to put forth the effort and
sacrifice to get there so while we did
not continue with this fast-paced hustle
culture these few years certainly
provided major change for our lives and
lastly the best financial decision that
i have made thus far is one that i am
still making one that is ever evolving
as i am ever changing
minimalism
it is not something that defines me but
rather a tool that allows me to live
life more slowly through minimalism i am
able to free myself from the excess
whether that be a chaotic schedule a
cluttered home or a cluttered mind
minimalism focuses on simplicity and
having more of what we love and what
excites us and less of those things that
add burden
as i near my thirties and i watch my
children grow
i am reminded that my time
is truly all that i have in this world
and it is passing before my eyes
i no longer want to waste this precious
time working overtime every week to
accumulate more stuff more clutter more
waste more stress to manage it all
i now choose to be free from the
constant desire to buy more stuff
and focus on slow intentional living to
find beauty
in simplicity so that is it for this
video these are my seven smartest
financial decisions that i have made or
am still making in my 20s if you have
liked this video please give it a thumbs
up and subscribe so that you won't miss
when i post a new video i thank you so
much for watching and i'll see you in
the next one bye for now